I lived in New York City and in New York
I had done off-broadway and paying rent
was always a challenge so I became a
photo editor for a very large photo
stock house for a number of years and
worked on independent films and
continued that a production designed
small films and art directed for years
and then very much settled in being a
set decorator unlike decoration or
interior design residential people feel
it's very isolated it may be interiors
or that you either do residential or
commercial and in film you you're handed
a script and you're challenged and
you're what you're what you're asked to
do or in telling a story can be
Interiors exteriors it could be planes
trains automobiles it just runs the
gamut so might the biggest miss Nomar is
that people just think it's moving
furniture or making choices and it is
about telling a visual narrative on
every level from bushes to glassware as
visual effects are changing the demands
of sets are changing dramatically the
speed in which things are done are
changing prep times are very much being
altered reduced in many many times and
the emphasis on how sets are being built
and what they what they attach to what
they're near so the the requirements of
what a set decorator does varies from
project project
you